I can keep my hood on my hair look kind
of crazy
so you're hiding everything it's like
I'm not I'm just I have a wig on cuz my
hair's not done
so I mean I think talking about the lazy
eye might
be something that we would do cuz Okay
CU that's something I am insecure about
makes I don't like other people noticing
and it makes me feel like well let's
just see what we can do here all right
all right
sweets sweets sweets uh where you from
sweets where'd you grow up uh I grew up
in Erie Pennsylvania mhm the East Coast
how was your childhood um I had a good
childhood I have a lot of siblings so I
grew up with a lot
of chaos cuz I have a lot of siblings
and stuff like that and um separation
too um your parents split up separation
like I wasn't always with all of my
siblings like we got separated so it was
like half of us with my mom and then the
other half of my grandpa and stuff like
that
so and why why did you guys get split up
uh it was something I had to do with my
dad um
so it was just something that happened
with him and he had to go away for a
minute and my mom she couldn't like do
it by herself so she went to where her
side of the family was when you say
something happened to your dad yeah he
went away like he had uh he had a
business trip he went something happened
he went to prison so I mean he wasn't
around for a minute but
yeah how how you how would you describe
your childhood in general um I had a I
had a pretty good childhood I had a
childhood like a real childhood like I
would say
like um I was being a child I would
wasn't doing too much like I was a good
child good in school all of that
like I was never in any trouble like
that never got any trouble was always
focused on getting good grades trying to
help people I like to help people so
that was one of my goals to like any
chance that I get I try to help anybody
like but but no abuse in your childhood
nothing like that no no abuse nothing
like that um just really just emotional
for myself probably like emotional
damage I don't know because um my mom
and dad being separated and stuff and
not being around like all of my
siblings like how we were but yeah was
it just you that was separated oh no it
was um because I have like 12 siblings
I'm know going to have 12 siblings so we
had to get separated like like that like
big groups like that so summer left with
my grandpa and then my mom took the
other half and we went to like her side
of the family to where she can actually
get help and like not do it by herself
so how old are you now um I'm 21 21 you
graduate high school yes what' you do
after that uh I went to college for a
little bit um I went to Vegas went to
UNLV for a little bit and then um I
don't know I just wanted a new
environment I was getting tired of Vegas
I decided to come to LA and I thought
that I would continue school here but
it's a lot of distractions here it's a
lot to get distracted easily by when
you're trying to do things for yourself
or just trying to when you're trying to
be focused on one thing comeing to La
you going to get distracted by a whole
lot of other things so did you do did
you have dreams of doing something with
your life yeah and I still will and I
still do yeah what would you like to do
uh I want to be a choreographer dancer I
like to cook I have like plan A B and C
so first I was going to go to the Army
and then I was like okay that's probably
like my last plan I leave that as Plan D
then I was like okay well I want to
think about being a nurse because like I
don't know no matter the situation
somebody might need help and you might
need a nurse somewhere like come out of
nowhere and Save Somebody life so I be
thinking about stuff like that so I do
want to like try to be a nurse and try
to like
um focus on that a little bit but I do
really like to dance so I want to be a
dancer and
choreographer so working figuro street
is is plan e no this is just actually
just in the midst of it it's not
something I do every day it's just fast
money to get to where like I need to be
a little quicker so it's not something
that I do every day it's not something
that I'm being forced to do it's not
something that you know but it is a lot
that I do go through doing what I do
being on Figo like for the time that I
have been on there for the little time
that I have been in Figaroa like since
the beginning of this year
um I've been through a lot I've been
through a lot of things like unexpected
things like just last week I have like
basically the worst week of probably
this year like the worst week of this
year like I got robbed and all type of
other things and it was just I don't
know it was hard but yeah that's Figo is
basically yeah you could say plan e
maybe Plan F Figo Plan F cuz that's not
good plan at all so it's just something
to get fast money it's not even part of
my plan to be honest and I don't like it
but are drugs a part of your life no no
drugs no drugs do you have a pimp no
you're just out here by yourself I have
some friends I mean I've got introduced
to this by a friend of mine when I moved
out here from Vegas we actually moved
out here together from Vegas we actually
do have regular jobs too but this is
something that we do also to get money
quicker because obviously this is this
money is faster than you know a regular
job so you know sometimes it be
like but yeah I came out here with a
friend of mine she introduced me to this
she was doing it when she was in Vegas I
didn't know so cuz I was just still
working my regular job I was in college
and all that stuff so when I got to La
she introduced me to it and I just
started doing it I did try to um get a
regular job and I do have regular job
but it's like I don't work every day so
the days where I don't work I go out on
fig basically
so so you have one eye that's a little
lazy I do and I you see I'm trying to
cover it and that is something I dealt
with a lot of my life conscious yes and
it that's something that actually is
something that never leaves a part of my
life is something that I deal with every
day somebody asks me something about
that every day makes you look like a
little cross yeah and that's that's one
thing too is that never feels every time
anybody knew that I meet they notice it
and that's like the thing I try to get
people not to notice like have you have
you seen a doctor about it or anything I
have and I was supposed to be getting
surgery and stuff like that and then I
decided like I didn't want to do it
anymore because I'm like okay I just
accept myself for who I am like not for
like what anybody else wants me to be
because like
I've been in situations where I've did
things for people
like before I ran into the girl that I
ran into that I'm doing this with I was
in a relationship with this girl and she
was actually doing this and I didn't
know that and she has a kid and stuff
like that
and and it's just crazy because she
would be going to Fig every day or
somewhere like Pomona or something I
wouldn't even know and I'll be watching
her son and stuff like that while she's
working and I wouldn't know anything
like that and it's like now that I'm
experiencing like the life that she was
doing like when I was wasn't doing it
it's like damn like I don't know how she
was even dealing with it because it be
like I don't know it just be
like half of this is not worth it
at all your life like it's not worth it
at all like mentally it puts you on a it
drains you mentally like it puts you on
a it puts you on a like
a type of mood or a type of like feeling
like I know you probably feel disgust I
know I don't know most girls probably
don't admit it
but I don't know I sometimes I feel
disgusted with myself for for what I do
for for doing this for even exposing
myself like this and I never I say that
I never seen myself doing this and I
would always talk about the girls that
do this and stuff like that and it's
like now that I'm doing it and it's like
I'm not anybody to judge anybody I
wasn't anybody to judge anybody for what
they were doing and what they were going
through and it's not like it's this
is hard this is not easy at all
like and now that I'm going through it
it's
like that is like I don't know and
I know I'm not making my family happy
it's like I know this is not making
anybody else happy it's not making me go
further in life with what I need to do
with myself and I feel like it's just
distracting me to be honest and I feel
like it's
just uh like the money is just the fast
money is the only thing that is the only
benefit like cuz mentally you're going
to be mentally you're going to be gone
mentally you're going to be drained like
mentally it's
like you're going to lose yourself
basically like you're going to lose
yourself being in this occupation you
would lose yourself and it would be a
lot that you have to gain back from
doing this and you got to be strong to
be doing this
because I don't know it's just like a
lot of people won't wouldn't even be
strong enough to go through a half of us
girls go through out here like I'm
sitting here nervous about exposing
myself right now I'm trying to hide what
I really do and I'm trying to make it
sound good but it's not good it's not
good I'm not any better than anybody out
here I can't hide myself like I'm tired
of hiding myself I'm tired of just
feeling
like I don't know I don't never I am
nervous right now I know that but like I
just
I never really talk to anybody about
everything that goes on out there
like most of us don't have a person to
really
like that listens to us we don't really
have a person that really like
understands that what we go through
every day like literally it's just like
like I know I look crazy right now but
it's
like I don't know it's it's it's hard to
be it's hard it's hard to feel good when
you it's hard to look good when you
don't feel good like it's hard to it's
hard to it's hard to like try to focus
on the good when it's just so much bad
happening it's hard to just focus on
something that's positive when it's just
so much negative coming around and just
crowding you and it's just this
occupation for us females is
like there other ways to do it it's
other ways to do it and I just don't
think this is the way and I don't I
don't know there's a lot of shame in
this isn't it yeah I feel a lot of Shame
too and it's like I don't know I really
do feel a lot of Shame from it because I
never thought that I would see myself
doing it but it's like now I understand
why most people do it now I do
understand it now I understand
like I'm really starting to understand
more parts of life than what I didn't
understand when I was younger so I just
turned 21 it's not a lot that I know
it's not a lot I probably ain't been
through as much as
all these other girls been through but
like mentally I can say we all got a
common is it's draining and mentally is
we have to be mentally strong like
literally we have to be mentally
like we had to have our mental up there
to be able to to do this every
day because if we don't then we will
lose ourself and that's how most girls
do get exposed to drugs like I'm not
I've only been doing this for like a
year
and I've had like the worst experiences
ever
like I I wear glasses I don't have my
glasses anymore because um this dude
that I knew from middle school seen me
on figuro I guess he didn't like that
but I haven't talked to him in years I
don't have nothing to do with him he
decided to try to rob me him and his
friend and they took my purse and my
phone and broke my glasses ran them over
and I was on fig all night like I
couldn't even get any type of help at
all like I couldn't get back to where I
needed to be like it's hard being out
there and it's hard especially when you
don't have anybody being out there when
you're by yourself like most girls have
pimps and stuff like that like but it's
hard being out there by yourself like
when something like that happens and you
need somebody to call and you don't have
nobody to call It's It just like I don't
know can can you see out of your left ey
no I can't to be honest it's not so it's
not so great everything is like half
like if I was to cover it like this it
would be I could just see like basically
everything over here but not clear but
you've talked to a doctor about getting
your eye fixed uh I have talked to a
doctor about getting my eye fix but um I
was really scared to do it to like I
don't know I was scared of the process
of getting surgery and stuff like that
and then I was just thinking like I
don't want to change myself for anybody
else but like I think it would give you
a lot of confidence though yeah yeah and
I do have a lot of confidence but it's
like when I start to really think about
it and I start to be like dang okay let
me just cover it up a little bit see if
make sure nobody notices it then that
makes me really like okay maybe I should
do something about it cuz if it bothers
me that much that I really try to hide
it that much you're a beautiful girl
thank you and if you had that little
thing fixed which I'm which I'm I'm
pretty certain they can fix effectively
then that might help your self-esteem it
might help you make better decisions for
your future I think it would I think
yeah it starts for me first I have to
love myself first I got to accept myself
first and it's like sometimes I can't
accept that I have a lazy eye cuz I hear
that I hear every day that everybody is
like it's nonstop like somebody come up
to me like I don't understand why people
do that but they'll just come up to me
are you cross-eyed what type of question
is that that's like a crazy question
like you were born this way
um to me I wasn't born this way I was
not born this way it was uh injury me
and my brother something happened I
forgot like my mom how my mom told me
that it happened but how it happened my
brother came down I we was on like a
slide or something I don't know my
brother came down and his teeth went in
my head and they were it was stuck it
was stuck it was on this side and it was
like stuck we had to go to the hospital
like with his teeth in my head and he
hit some type of nerve or something like
that and I don't know it just never got
right and yeah the doctor said it would
get right over time and the years p and
this seemed like it got worse to be
honest so and like the more and more
that I think about it more and more that
everybody reminds me and I hear it every
day or you're crossy or you have a lazy
eye or I don't know cuz the most it
seems like it bothers other people more
than it bothers me like I try not to let
it bother me and then it's like it
bothers me all over again because
somebody reminds me of it or somebody
just like I don't know like say say
something about it like it's bothering
them about it
like it's my body it's my eye I can't
control that I literally can't control
it like it's that bad like and I do deal
with issues out there even on figuro
being out there a lot of girls first I
don't know why but I know I do look
young but a lot of girls think I'm young
because a a lazy eye or because they say
like it's childish that I'm crossy I've
heard this story like plenty of times so
I know it's crazy that I'm saying it but
I've heard from a lot of girls like you
got to be a kid or or this this a that
because like I'm crossided or I have a
lazy eye and stuff like that and I don't
know there's one girl I interviewed
who's blind she's literally blind she
she can barely she can't even look at a
dollar bill and tell you what what
what's how much it is
wow and that's kind of if I didn't have
this eyeball that's how I would be and I
still wouldn't let that Define me and I
feel like I feel like I sometimes let
what people say like get to me because
it is true like okay people say oh are
you crossided or whatever I try to
correct them and say I just have a lazy
eye like cuz I don't like that I don't
like what people call me cross-side like
it really it does hurt my feelings
because I mean I am but I don't like to
say like oh I'm cross- sided like cuz I
think it's a difference between being
lazy ey and crossy like it's a big
difference and most people don't know
that difference and I do get defensive
and I get mad sometimes when people
bring it up and it makes me upset so I
deal that every day like that's
something I do
it every day of my life and also my
facial facial features cuz I look young
most people think I'm a little kid or a
minor
or you know just I don't know even know
I'm 21 years old like your your family
didn't look into getting surgery to help
right uh my mom asked me if I wanted to
and stuff like that she cared she asked
me I told her I didn't want to I told
her I didn't care what anybody else
thought I told her I was okay with how I
looked I told her like I accepted I
accepted my looks I accepted me for who
I was I accepted me for who God but just
as someone who just met you I
would I I would think so getting that
fixed would would change a lot about
your the way you see yourself the way
you others see you it would help your
confidence tremendously I
think I agree with that and I think I
keep trying
to put in my head that nothing is wrong
with me or that I there's nothing I need
to change about myself and that's a good
attitude but this is the real world and
you know an employer and I do it's it's
it's hateful people in this world there
people in this world that really make
you feel
like make you feel how you feel like you
know like so like I I do understand that
and I do know that I should probably I
do I'm not GNA lie I do want to get it
fixed like it does bother me a lot and I
do want to get it fixed and I do but I
just try to accept it for who I am
because some people tell me like that
makes you who you are so like don't
change it that makes you who you are but
like deep down inside me I feel like as
a
person I don't feel as beautiful as
other people see me because of my eye or
because of how much I've got um bullied
about it and stuff like and it really
does hurt my feelings because it's
something I I can't control so it's not
my fault like and I don't like anybody
on there anybody wrong with anybody I
don't point that out like you're a big
person you're a fat person you're a
skinny person I don't point that out
about people because I'm a kind person
like and some some words do hurt even
though you shouldn't let words get to
you but it's like when you hear those
words like almost every day in your life
and you like nonstop constantly it's
like probably not a day goes by when you
don't hear
anything it's like it's it's hard it's
hard to like okay it's nothing that you
need to change about yourself when you
constantly get reminded every day about
what you need to change about what you
probably want to change deep down inside
like no but but this is the real world
and people do judge on appearance and if
you're working a straight job
or meeting a guy that might you might
start a romantic relationship with I
would
think that little detail which is easily
fixed is going to play a large part in
in in how everything plays out in your
life which might lead you to the
situation that you're in now yeah I feel
like if I meet the right person I accept
me for who I am and make me feel like
make me love my lazy eye then that would
make me not want to change it but till
then I just I deep down I do want to
change it but I just try to convince
myself that I don't and that I'm okay
with it cuz I am okay with it but at the
same time I'm not because I think I'm
Different a lot different than a lot of
people because first of all I can't even
see straight everybody else can see
straight I can't see straight so like of
course I'm Different I just be I just be
thinking about all of that stuff so and
then and then you're getting picked up
by guys and they're using you for one
thing and B like use me for one thing so
of course they probably don't see the
thing that I see they probably don't see
like my flaws that I see they only see
one thing because they only want one
thing
so being out on figs I'm not looking for
anybody to see me as beautiful or
anything like that cuz I know what
they're looking for
like but I do appreciate the nice and
the kind people that do tell me that
thank you I really do yeah cuz you seem
like a good-hearted girl you're be
you're beautiful as well I am this one
you know it's like it's almost like
you're just missing a tooth you can go
to a dentist and get that fixed it it'll
it'll change your to your self your
self-image and your the image that you
project onto everyone that meets
you I never really got into it like this
how I am now and I'm actually glad that
I am because I haven't really tapped
into the things I need to tap into like
like that for example that does really
trigger me that does
really I do really deal with a lot with
that and you you have your whole life
ahead of you and I'm only 21 literally I
would think it would change the whole
trajectory of your life if you had this
looked at a different type of confidence
that's what I need to have and I think I
will too because I don't want to just be
worried about what other people think on
my life I mean I'm not but at the same
time you hear so much at one point
you're going to like it's not a day go
by where
I I don't hear it it's always a day
where I always get reminded of it all
the time everyone that meets you says
something huh everyone that meets you
will say something a lot of people a lot
of people I mean today this girl she was
okay so I seen this girl on fig and um
she thought it was a minor her and three
other girls walked up to me asked for my
ID me I don't have to prove myself to
anybody ex if you're not the police or
anybody else I don't feel like I don't
have to give you my ID so I told her I
don't have to show her my ID and I seen
her again today tonight she was like oh
the crossy one it's you again it's just
crazy how she pointed that out
like she pointed that out like oh the
crossided one even though I'm the one
who ID she asked for I'm like Oh you
mean the one ID you asked for and then
she said no I never asked for your ID
she don't even remember ask for my ID
but she remember my my crossy like but
she don't remember asking for my ID like
people remember you by different things
and a lot of people remember me by that
is that was her second time seeing me
she don't even remember ask me from my
ID should remember me from my lazy eye
but hearing you speak about it I could
tell you that if you change that so much
more so so many other things would
change about your
life just the way you the way you carry
yourself the way you put yourself out
there in the world you know the kind of
work that
you go after the kind of relationships
you go after everything would probably
change and it's it's probably a simple
fix I agree with that
I think that is a change that I do need
to make because that does affect a lot
of my myself as a person it affects cuz
it starts with me loving myself it
starts with me accepting myself so like
if I don't even do that then I don't
know how I'm going to move forward to
any other thing so I do appreciate that
because I I don't usually like talk
about my lazy eye at all I really don't
this is the most time I ever talked
about
it I give
About It by keeping it hidden by keeping
it in the closet not talking about it
yeah I I I treat it I how I don't talk
about it is how I treat it like I I try
to hide it I try to I try to just avoid
it so that's how I do when I talk about
it I try not to talk about it I try to
hide it I try to avoid it I try
to like I don't know I try to look as
straight as I can but I can't like I
don't know it's it's hard for me it's
things that I can't control
so that's one thing that I can't
something you can get fixed and it is
and I think it is something I will get
fixed in the future
because I need to feel
better as a person I need to love myself
as a person and I let a lot of things
get to me of what other people said to
me because I am a really nice genuine
person so I I sometimes I do let a lot
of things get to me what people say so
sometimes it does really hurt my
feelings I had to work on that
too we all have something to work
on but you know as an outsider just who
just met you I would say that would be
something worth looking at thank you I
agree with that I also agree with
that you you know it it it also created
a sensitivity in you for other people
they're going through struggles yeah I
know most girls probably don't point out
their flaws like that like
I'm I'm a real I'm a real young lady so
I don't I don't mind doing that putting
on my flaws Nobody's Perfect it's like
I'm not better than anybody either and I
know it's a lot of girls that deal with
things that they probably don't talk
about that they probably don't talk
about that I probably mention right now
like they probably feel disgusted with
their themselves most of the times like
they probably feel like they can never
be in a relationship because of the what
they did in their life before this or
because of this like I don't know it's
just a lot that
I hope I've mentioned some things that a
lot of people don't talk about that are
sensitive about I hope I mention some
things and I hope I can help some people
with it because I know I'm not the only
one that deals with that like I'm not
insecure or none of that but it's just
like constantly hearing every day
literally not a day goes past when I
don't get reminded about my lazy eye
when of course I know I look at myself
every day in the mirror so like when
other people remind me of it it' be like
damn like okay you I wake up and look at
myself in the Maryland and see myself no
but you're you're a very beautiful girl
thank you and I can see that that little
thing that people kind of focus on yeah
would you know would change everything
for
you I feel like it would too I feel like
it would just changed my whole
perspective how I look at myself
and cuz when people do say things to me
I do let it get to me and I be like okay
but I I try to say like that's not true
and stuff like that
like even though it's something that
they're talking about it's a sensitive
topic and they're talking about
something I actually am sensitive about
which is my odd because I do have a lazy
eye so that's that is hard for me to
really just hear but I've learned to
accept it a little but at the same time
I
still deep down I still I would love I
would love to interview you in a couple
years after you've had it fixed and to
see where your life
goes see how things have
changed I think that would be a good
idea I think it would be a traumatic
change I think it would be
a a good change yeah I think it' be very
dramatic change and I agree with that I
think I just need to love myself more
and I need to do things for myself more
I don't do things for myself as much as
I do things for other people I don't
really how I care for other people is
not how I really care for myself and
that's a problem
because I should have been try to think
about I should have been tried to make
myself happy I should have been tried to
I should have got that surgery because I
know like deep down it does bother me so
I should have got it like and I wanted
to get it but me hearing other people
tell me like that's what makes you you I
didn't want to change that but that's
not that that's not what makes me me
that's what I've been through that makes
me
me not who I am not my occupation or not
how I look or anything like that like
you have an education you've been to
little College you you've and I can
still go back to college whenever I want
too it's like I have a lot of
opportunities but I came to LA and I got
distracted and it was like a it's a lot
of distractions when you come to La like
it's a lot of opportunities but a lot of
distractions as well so if you're coming
here for one thing you're going to get
distracted and that's what I did I
supposed to be going back to college and
stuff like that but to even get stable I
didn't even have a car so I thought
being on Figaroa getting fast money
would help me get a car had a car got in
a car accident now I'm trying to get
another card so it's just like
a big process but yeah I feel like me
once I get my confidence I had to get my
confidence on a higher level for myself
so that I can love myself how I need to
love myself because right now I'm not
going to lie I feel like sometimes I
don't love myself
how I used to before I started
this before I started being on figur I
feel like I don't love myself as much as
I used to it's got to impact your self
as
selfworth yeah I feel like I don't know
I feel like a lot of Shame like I said a
lot of Shame a lot
of disgust I guess
like it's just a lot that I feel being
in this occupation because like but you
got to be strong you can't let it can't
let the occupation like can't let what
you're
doing Define you or your environment
Define you this environment does not
define me this environment is crazy I
need to be in a different area or
something like that
but
yeah that will be something I will get
fixed to be honest and I am going to
accept that because I'm I be trying to
say like no I don't need to get that
fixed but I do want to I do want to do
that for myself CU that's going to make
myself feel good and I want to make
myself feel good I want to do something
for myself to make myself feel good so I
think I do want to do that like I try to
say I
don't really talking about it right now
I think I need to I think I want to well
I can I can see how beautiful you are
inside and out and I feel like I'm not
as beautiful on the outside because of
one little simple thing like I feel like
that just makes my whole I don't know
and I shouldn't even feel like that
because I am beautiful but it's like my
lazy eye I feel like that throws a lot
of it throws it off so it's easily
fixable I
think
yeah yeah but it's just like a process I
try to go through the process where I
don't have to get surgery like my eye
doctor I would have to cover the good
eye and let that eye work but this eye
don't work and I never did that at all
so it that didn't work and you have onee
works works
fine surgery whether you got it fixed
for cosmetic reasons or help to help
your vision or both both e either way it
would be great I think both really for
my vision because that's really was
affected me like it's hard for me to see
as it is I wear glasses and I don't have
my glasses so it's hard and then it's
like
um when I do be on fig without my
glasses I'm just mentioning this right
now when I do be on fig without my
glasses I really cannot see so like it
be like hard for me to just walk up to
cars or just walk up to anybody or wave
at anybody cuz I don't know who I'm
waving I can't see you
so yeah most of the time I do try not to
go to Fig all the time like if I could
just meet up with the people I know I'll
just do that
but it's hard being on fig with a with a
yes it is hard being on fig with a lacy
eye believe it or not it is I'm sure
definitely is so it's hard to go through
life that way I think it's hard it's
hard with a lot of it's hard with a lot
of stuff for real especially when when I
was in school glad I got that over with
I'm glad I graduated when I was in
school that definitely affected me a
lot yeah but I I think you are naturally
beautiful thank you just the way you are
I mean like like that that that crazy
wig you're wearing take off that wig
okay I'll bet you you're beautiful
underneath
there
okay that's your real hair uh most of it
yes braids right now beautiful thank
you oh my God you're such a beautiful
girl thank
you I'm just a little bit shy but yeah
but you have a reason that you know
anyone would be shy given it's hard for
me to make like the that's another thing
I feel like that affects me a lot too
because like with interviews and stuff
it's hard for me to give direct eye
contact and I know that's important with
interviews and all a lot of things so I
do need to get my lazy eye fixed because
I can't even make like straight direct
eye contact because I feel like it's
just noticeable so I look away so quick
and like I don't know that's going to
affect me when I'm doing an interview
for a job and stuff CU I have been
through that so or dating a guy or or
anything yeah it's going to affect me
with a lot of things not just a job so
and most importantly your just your
selfworth yes my selfworth and yeah I
tried to hide myself but I shouldn't do
that I think you're beautiful thank you
I think the more you love love yourself
and do the right things for yourself the
better your life is going to get and I
agree with that and I have to do more
for myself instead of for other people
cuz I don't know I realize I do more for
other people than myself
so that's true but I don't mind because
I'm a helpful person I like helping
people so but I do have to think about
myself at the end
so yeah I like you much better without
the crazy wig thank you me
too it was crazy dang
all right sweets thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I'd love i'
love to see you again in a couple years
okay thank you that'd be great thank
you